estos manifestantes en las calles de la
segunda ciudad de mianmar mandalay
quizás sean sólo unos pocos pero la
alarma por el abrupto cambio de
liderazgo en el país es generalizada
muchos temen que cualquier manifestación
pueda ser reprimida por los militares
estamos protestando de forma no violenta
contra el golpe de estado no podemos
aceptar el golpe militar y el uso del
poder y las armas
[Música]
este es el sonido de la tambaleante
democracia de mianmar
con cacerolazos por segunda noche
consecutiva los manifestantes
denunciaron el golpe militar en un
intento para frenar las protestas la
junta interrumpió temporalmente el
acceso a internet y bloqueó facebook que
los manifestantes utilizan para
organizarse para saltarse las
restricciones a la aplicación de
mensajería por bluetooth wi-fi ha sido
descargada más de un millón de veces en
jean marc por otra parte los médicos de
varios hospitales estatales como este de
jan wijn se niegan a trabajar para el
nuevo gobierno y dicen que sólo
realizarán tratamientos de urgencia
estos lazos rojos simbolizan su apoyo al
que debería ser el actual partido
gobernante y la liga nacional para la
democracia no quiero que mis hijos
crezcan bajo el régimen militar quiero
ser una buena madre una ciudadana
responsable y también una buena doctora
[Música]
el lunes los militares derrocaron y
arrestaron a la líder democráticamente
elegida a un sandwich y desde entonces
fueron presentados cargos en su contra
por supuestamente violar las leyes de
importación y exportación del país